um what is Womanhood to you wow
I don't know having pierced everyone
it's hang on go on having periods every
month but whatever there's there's some
women who don't have periods oh someone
we can get rid of their parents yeah
true and but maybe talking of majority
though
so is it just biological physical yeah
what is it to be a woman because it's
biological because yeah because as you
know because I feel like men in this
trans movement are encroaching upon
Womanhood
I feel like it's for women to push back
and say no this is what it actually is
to be a woman this might be a good
question this might be a good time to
illustrate a difference is there a
difference between gender and sex there
is by definition they're tired
I think they're tied together I believe
you can't yeah they're connected you
can't have sex without the agenda XY
chromosomes exist and xx chromosomes
exist I thought I was fought gender was
something to do with language like
agenda in terms of like you know in
French there's the you can express the
things in the masculine or the feminine
yeah yeah yeah but of course for
literature not for but what is Womanhood
to you though like what is Womanhood
Jazz like what is it
it's like easy but hard at the same time
because you don't want to suggest
subjectify it to oh or you can
um have babies this that in the third
because there's going to be women that
are in look at you as like well am I not
Con in my is my Womanhood taken away
from me because I can't have a child but
if we were to break everything down into
our DNA it would come down to that and
then the anatomy we have as women that's
something that you cannot
right now you cannot add to
um you cannot change your DNA you cannot
add to your body a uterus a womb the
feet now you can't know
show me I'm just saying they're doing it
like they're doing like womb transplants
when it works let me know I'm actually
so surprised that the three of you
actually struggle to answer that
question like you know what it is you
know what it is I'm still young I'm 18
okay cool fine you can come for me I'm a
baby
but like even like I've never been able
to answer that question do you know why
do you know what I think and please
excuse me if I'm wrong because you just
live it it's just you it's just yeah you
don't even you don't think about it
exactly you don't even think about right
what what do what is me right but I
think especially now when we're talking
about all these different identities and
what people classify as what it's hard
like it's hard to know okay what does a
woman look like yes and I think even
when we were talking about the masculine
and feminine energy this is why I keep
asking you what does a masculine or
feminine energy look like because
nowadays it's so subjective it's not one
simple definition it's definitely a Vibe
I think it's no longer just as simple as
okay yes your biological features
nowadays everywhere you go there'll be
different definitions of a woman of a
masculine or a feminine of a man and
it's like well I don't really know what
I am supposed I'm just trying to do my
best so then all jokes are sad me being
Pearl right all jokes aside if I was to
grow my hair
get breast implants
remove my penis and get that operation
would as a woman
would you consider me a woman
um to respect you yes to respect your
decision that you made yes but it would
it would be like when I do see men that
have transitioned into being a woman I'm
like okay great that was your choice but
it it hurts because it's like is it that
easy to become right a woman and you
don't have to go through the pain of it
I'll also give you some for example as
well so for example if you go to Morocco
right there's a tradition that you need
to go to hamam if you know what Hama
means so just like
everyone gets the boss to get like have
a bath together like all women of for
example for Community we have a bot
together it's just like a thing I might
want to go to Hamilton
guys
right so as per what you said and you
just
transform yourself put a transplant
everything
I wouldn't feel comfortable going with
you to the hamam knowing that you are a
transgender woman right but that's why
you just said you accept him
I will accept you I will respect you but
at the same time I wouldn't feel
comfortable with you to do some stuff
for example
she is now but you were still not a
biological woman have you noticed that
women find it harder yeah have you
noticed that women find it harder to
yeah to just tell it the way it is I was
genuinely grimacing when you guys said
like well yeah to respect you I'm like
oh you saw my face I was like yeah
if if he if you genuinely decided to
transition
how is that bothering me yeah if this if
this individual decided to be a woman
today
I'm trying to say many many things won't
affect your life but you look at from
the from the perspective of where is
society going I think everyone cares
about Society that's why it has to be
regulated and with with what they were
just talking about there has to be a a
um what was it Hammer yeah hammer for
Natural Born women right here but that's
not inclusive bro it doesn't have to be
inclusive respecting genders just like
you can't say inclusivity and be like
well men and women should be together
Sarah is now Sarah
I'm actually Pearl but
he's on maneuvers looking for a naked
bath with ladies all right he's on
maneuvers right now yeah but what I'm
saying expect that that's down to
society to regulate it and we're
regulating it poorly by being inclusive
of most I wouldn't say everything but
most things I don't think there's
anything wrong with anybody
transitioning as long as it's regulated
but we are part of society yeah we've
got three ladies here that couldn't no
we have a straight answer we've got four
ladies
could be an offensive to the idea of the
concept why is it offensive I could tell
you right now what a man is I I could
actually probably give a better idea
that's the thing with men yeah yeah men
understand their manhood yeah right and
we always understand their manhood
because with our manhood right we it's
it's like a it's just a psychological
thing like it's innate we know what it
is if a bunch of women today started
transitioning and saying yeah we're men
no you ain't no period no hell no you
ain't whereas women have tended to
accept men transitioning into women
saying we're women like that oh well you
know if you feel like that then it's
fine and that's the difference between
men and women because men are gonna tell
it straight down the line how it is and
I feel like you see you talking about
regulate it's for men to regulate it and
I've said before I actually feel like
men of this of this time are doing the
job that I personally feel yeah women
should be doing because women should be
checking other with these guys yeah yeah
yeah saying you ain't no woman yeah
right but you can't comment you can't
come into my thing saying that yo
because I know what it is because I know
men would do that we would be like these
bunch of women coming to say that amen
no no no no no no no push back on that
one is that you have to remember what
these ladies just demonstrated is their
disagreeableness I agreeableness yeah
exactly because they were rather not
offend and tell the truth that's right I
think there's a there's a there's a sign
that says truth no love without truth is
sentimentality but truth without love is
harshness so it's
um but they've had they've got love
without truth it's sentimentality she's
saying it's their nature is that it's
this in general not all women are like
this but most women in general could
rather say you know I'd rather keep the
relationship it's good for Society for
that to have that yeah but I'd like to
mention as men we will say yeah
going back to one of um his points he
mentioned that
um you were talking about uh respect you
were saying if it doesn't bother me yeah
then I have no problem respecting you I
think that makes sense I feel like if
I'm not being harmed I think when it
comes to the toilet discussion I
personally wouldn't feel comfortable
yeah and in that case when it comes to
the Hammer discussion exactly exactly I
would not feel comfortable in that case
I would like actually you know what
respectfully no not happening when it
comes to sports however if it's just a
case of okay you transitioning that does
not personally affect me that doesn't
personally harm me that doesn't
personally calls me discomfort so I can
respect you yes you're an athlete
Leah Thomas you've spoken about it
before yes we have the man who now is a
swimmer became the swimmer be all of the
female swimmers yes biological male
biological male that's the correct term
is that man but biological male okay
um that went into the swimming
competition How would how do you feel as
an athlete for that to happen so you
kept bringing up that needs to be
regulated that is one of the areas that
I think that it has to be regulated like
there's no if ands or buts about it if
you are going to transition if there is
not a specific team that you can play on
that is your specific demographic
because that right now that's what it is
your specific demographic you are born a
woman and you're still a woman you're
born a male and you're still a male
that's the demographic of the team you
can play on I do not think that they
should intermingle the
um that the people who are transitioning
trans men are trans women because there
are biological differences that are
going to forever be like that because of
just what a man gets when he is his DNA
is transformed into a man and what a
woman gets between the um the hormones
but we're all equal
no
if we were all if we were all equal
across the board there would there will
would not need there would not need to
be a need for
um male or female at all we were the
same I also I also think that we're all
equal until it suits you as women and
I'll explain this and I don't mean that
in a general term I really mean that in
like things that you've just stated you
stated that it's okay for someone to
transition because it doesn't affect you
but you've also stated that oh if I go
to the toilet I'm probably gonna feel
uncomfortable or if I'm in a pool with a
biological male I'm gonna feel
uncomfortable
there's a contradiction in what you said
because the first instant of the person
transitioning doesn't affect you
necessarily right there and then right
but the aftermath the effects that it
has in society will directly impact the
end affect you guys exactly the effect
it has in society is based on what
Society is allowing the effects to be
because if if let's say half or if half
of all males in the western
um civilization decided to transition
and Society said you're going to have
your own toilets there will be no
effects there'll be zero effects if you
regulate it
and there are effects because we're
letting anything and everything happen
we're allowing
um um transitioned men to say to share
toilets with natural born women
societies well whoever's allowing it is
allowing it
it's when you say effect I don't think
it's it's not a natural effect it's not
something that's just happening it's
something that's been allowed to happen
if I start a fight yeah if I start a
fire
can I control how it can where the fire
is going to go it goes yes
what I want to put forth to you is the
idea that although you may try to there
will be other avenues where that fire
will go Ablaze even if he tries the best
Society is already regulated there's
certain things I can't just walk into
the woman's toilets yes you can I mean I
can but I mean if but it's already there
are there's structures in place like the
government has a lot of structures in
places already regulated and we're
saying that are working they need they
need to do a better they just need to be
strict with them I don't think my thing
is you can only like regulate it from
the root you need to stop it from the
root you need to nip it in the bud like
but I have a clear distinction this is
this can't be happening this can be
happening Yeah by allowing people to
pick and choose when they do certain
things such as like trans the
transgender movement okay if I become a
woman I'm now allowed to do this one you
should have rules to say no yeah
but if you do you're a transfer yeah but
if you were transfer because we're
allowing that term to stick like yeah
welcome to the party man
internally yeah not yet anyway yeah but
what you're saying is you're saying if
it doesn't affect me Let It Go but then
you're talking about regulate yeah and I
can't get my head around what I'm saying
so if you if if you decide to transition
that's cool
you can't then dictate what your
transition means to society and we can't
just say okay cool yeah that's what it
means and we're going to accept that
that's what's happening why is it
happening that's my point like why is it
happening I think what's happening
people are scared to be heroes I think
what happens is if you want to be a hero
you won't get the glory now you will get
the glory in future so for example every
hero that we worship or figure look at
Nelson Mandela yeah William Wallace yeah
um William Tyndale or they were called
crazy as soon as they said yeah years
later that we go oh if I was in that
time I would have stood by William
Wallace and all the people that wanted
to end slavery trust me if you were if
you were living at that time where they
wanted to end slavery like William
Wilberforce he was the MP that tried to
end slavery in the 1700s can I just can
I just give you some contest because it
wasn't just really movable yeah it was
also oloda equiano who was actually a
Nigerian yeah exactly just to give some
context because there are black people
involved too so all I'm saying is that
you know a lot of people say if I was
living in that time I would have been
one of those people that would have
stood up against the the the
um consensus of slavery was okay in fact
a lot of people were arguing that the
Slaves Life to be slaves yeah yeah so
I'm just saying hindsight's incredible
yeah but then Jordan Peterson actually
said most people think
that during the time of Hitler that they
would have been on the side of the Jews
no they would have been Nazis
isha's point where he was talking about
okay so you're saying
um tackled the issue at the root cause
so in this case people transitioning
into different genders
yeah so
where I'm trying to go with this is that
okay if we're talking about okay
tackling from so let's say we don't
allow people to transition
what do you think is better people
identifying as a gender or people
transitioning into a gender because
there's problems with both so do we
prefer someone just going around saying
I'm a man I'm a woman I'm not
transitioning because apparently it's
going to be a problem to you but
um so is it easier for me to just
identify as someone and go about my
business there or is it easier for me to
transition instead
I think the issue comes into play when
I'm in an Institute and I'm now being
told
I have to address you as they or she
yeah and it's been frowned upon by
I'd say the higher the higher powers
that be that will then implicate
um repercussions on the companies for
the views that I may hold for not
wanting to believe in your rhetoric um
it's I I'd say
I can't take you seriously if you ain't
snipped
because you're not serious you've got to
be as a man to take your balls off his
chair like you gotta be like you gotta
be serious about your thing to get rid
of them do you got what I'm saying like
if you haven't snipped
I ain't taking you seriously yeah just
like as a woman
yes yeah you're trying something because
I have courage as a man I believe I have
you know all of these things how much
courage it must take as a man to take
your balls off
that's how I know you're serious about
your feet I'll be like you know what
respect you know
that spec you're serious about your
thing